we have to understand that every rule
that gets written has a cost
I don't think parents get that under the
headline we're going to keep your
children safe we're going to protect the
kids that that's really code for we're
taking your rights away hi I'm Nicolas
be with Reason TV and today we are
talking with Abbey Schachter she is a
longtime journalist and the author of
the fabulous new book No Child Left
alone getting the government out of
parenting Abbey thanks for talking to us
it's great a beer the book is all about
how government at all levels and other
kind of buttinsky groups are getting
more and more involved in the raising of
children of child-rearing give some of
the most exemplary illustrations of just
how annoying and frustrating this is and
why don't you start with your your
daycare experience that you start the
book with right so I didn't set out to
be a radical I just wanted my kids
swaddled at daycare
but that isn't okay with the state of
Pennsylvania and it's where I drew the
line and got into this subject we have
four children they've all gone to state
licensed daycare there were a huge
number of rules and regulations that
were annoying but we lived with them and
then the fourth one was born and we
brought him to daycare at nine weeks of
age and I they said what do you want us
to know about him and I said one thing
please swaddle him tightly and that
means wrapping the baby in a how do you
like it so that they yes it's been done
for thousands of years there was the
only parenting book we actually read and
follow dr. Harvey Karp I'm a big
proselytizer for him happiest baby on
the block all our children sleep because
of swaddling so that was it that's all I
wanted and the daycare said we need a
doctor's note because the state of
Pennsylvania otherwise bans swaddling in
daycare so I said that is crazy I've
never heard of such a thing and I pushed
you too far they pushed me too far I
just said that is it and I said I'm
donning my cape I am now captain mommy
I'm taking charge
and I thought oh okay I'll just get the
doctor's note I actually started off
thinking this will be a reasonable
reasonably easy thing to get done and it
turns out it's not because some of the
same people who are pushing this kind of
overly broad definitions of safety and
lack of acceptance of risk are the
people who the doctors pediatricians go
to to get opinions for how they should
advise their patients so that is I mean
one clear case of government regulation
or of you know some kind of authority
coming in and saying no you you've got
to do it this way in this circumstance
what are a couple of others so the worst
example are the dozens of cases of the
state coming and taking custody of
children who are morbidly obese these
are heartbreaking stories the family
tends to be unhealthy not just the child
and and they are really unhealthy but
the state says that the best they can do
is remove a child from its family
causing other damage but they're gonna
they're gonna try and solve in quotes
this one problem and that's the super
fat kid that's the super circuit does it
work is it effective at least well it
depends who you talk to there are lots
of doctors who say just force them to
have surgery
I mean bariatric surgery a teenager
could live a much longer life than
trying to change behavior behavior
modification is actually very difficult
to achieve successfully and yet this is
basically saying that's what we're going
to do yeah I was gonna say I mean that's
hard for individuals you know who are
really dedicated to it but then to get a
bureaucrat to do to make somebody else
pay attention you also talk about the
war on fun and the kind of play deficit
right so there's there are all kinds of
experts who will talk about Peter gray
talks about this a lot you know the the
deficit of unsupervised imaginative free
play amongst kids some of that is
parents they don't want to let the kids
out of the house so they over schedule
them okay
but if you don't have recess at school
which a lot of parents are fighting for
if you ban certain activities sledding
in a public playground running
in a public space pushing other kids on
the swing so all kinds of activities end
up being banned not because the
government comes along or the school
system comes along and says hey we don't
want these kids to have any fun but they
are defining a problem and they are
solving it in their
easiest sort of overly broad way which
is we're just going to ban it so why why
is this kind of stuff happening now I've
been writing about the different
experience of childhood you know from my
childhood to my kids child for 20 years
my kids are now 22 and 14 and in the 90s
when I started thinking about this stuff
I realized wow their lives are so
different than the ones the one I grew
up in and mine was you know on another
planet from my parents so why is this
kind of structure happening is it simply
that in two-income households both
parents are away and you put your kids
into institutionalized settings more is
it you know ridiculous over estimations
of risk what's going on here I think
that it's a combination of things I
think there has been several media
hysterias having to do with children
right abduction was one and this is a
mythology that has so taken root that we
have had low crime rates for 15 years
and I still get people reacting to my
book saying but the kid could get
abducted you know I does that linger so
long and how does it continue to inform
policy and kind of mental maps well
because they went we moved from
abductions let's say to the hysteria
over Satanism at daycare right that was
the 90s I would hate extra save but if I
could have gotten my kid into the st. no
strike and at least if I could have done
that now it would have been cheaper yeah
they would have been swaddling I'm sure
that would have been a reason to try to
I think that it's it's all of these
hysterias that have taken hold and it's
an and anxiety is really hard to come
back I mean that's really I think that's
a larger part of this you also talked
about
you reference a Phillip K Howard the
author who's best-known book is the
death of common sense you know and he
talks a lot about how people often times
in a good-natured way or in a good-faith
way say look this is just common sense
let's put a law in or or a process and
then it it goes in a very different
direction is that is that a contributing
factor here the kind of over lawyer ring
of everything you're wearing I mean look
part of it is practical the trial
lawyers get work right if you can sue
and we don't have a reform as simple as
loser pays then you have an incentive to
sue the municipality if your kid gets
hurt sledding and these municipalities
are struggling to pay their pensions so
they don't want to fight a lawsuit
they'll they'll settle and then they'll
just ban the activity so some of these
critiques and in in in in Howard's case
he's absolutely right also about the
nature of the regulation we don't say
our value is X and therefore we want to
allow people to achieve that value
whether it be safety or reducing risk
you find a way to do it right what we
say is you have to have the hooks in
daycare this far apart because that's
the safety standard right right so so
we're not really being we're not being
led by general principles or goals it's
rather than very kind of literal and
specific absolutely and you see that
everywhere and and you see that with
sort of the Consumer Product Safety
Commission their labels right they are
all so there's no common sense and their
warning labels because what do they put
on the warning labels for baby seats
don't put this on a high surface where
the baby might fall I mean you would
think this is common sense right instead
they hounded the manufacturer of a
particular of the Bumbo and now they
changed the name of the product so now
it's called the bumble floor seat right
as if it was too difficult for people to
understand that it was not meant to be
put up on a table or a chair it was
meant to sit on the floor and that would
be the safest place well here's a
challenges
is it possible you know we know from
looking at the results of school tests
for K through 12 students for it you
know going back to the early seventies
when they started doing this we're not
the kids aren't getting any smarter
maybe parents aren't as smart as they
once were that's also possible I mean I
wouldn't put it but I I would say that I
have found some very smart parents
writing this book No Child Left alone I
tried to enter as many examples of
parents who like myself just said this
is the stupidest thing I've ever heard
of in my life and I want to be left
alone to parent my own kid and talk a
bit about what so what is the cure where
do we go from here because you're
against the idea that there is a kind of
big switch where we can go from insanity
to sanity right what are the types of
activities what are the types of things
that can happen to kind of free our
children and and by extension free us as
parents to you know kind of live in a
world that is more interesting and
exciting and ultimately better for both
parents and children so the two things I
would suggest are one bring the
problem-solving closer to the supposed
problem I had to go and find the people
who made up this rule about swaddling
and they weren't in my state and they
weren't even accountable they couldn't I
couldn't yell at them because it wasn't
their fault they wrote a nice book of
guidelines and the other thing I would
say is that we have to understand that
every rule that gets written has a cost
I don't think parents get that under the
headline we're going to keep your
children safe we're going to protect the
kids that that's really code for we're
taking your rights away would you draw a
connection between the way that we treat
our children when they're kind of in you
know K through 12 or when they're living
at home with us would you would you
trace a line from that and kind of the
infantilization of kids in a way that is
more than it used to be and parents
because parents aren't allowed to make
choices is that part of what we're
seeing on college campuses when we see
either administrators or even students
themselves demanding a kind of more
infantile safe space and
college campus I mean it's hard for me
to say that it's a direct line but
certainly there's an influence because
what you're hearing about what happens
to college kids is they get there and
they don't know how to live in a world
that isn't a safe space so they're
demanding it because that's what they
have experienced if you're also coming
from a place where you were never you
never rode the city bus anywhere you
never got anywhere on your own or your
time was all managed by somebody else
you really aren't gonna have that many
skills and you really are going to think
who would have in your life come to you
and said no you actually have to do this
for yourself now because the some
parents haven't been doing that and
certainly your teachers haven't been
saying that and your and the government
is not saying that there they've been
saying the opposite well we will leave
it there we have been talking with a
bee-sh actor she is the author of the
excellent book No Child Left alone
getting the government out of parenting
Abbey thanks for talking to us pleasure
thank you for raising TV I'm Nick
Gillespie